Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. I just want to make a quick video about Protocell.
Protocell is a common nutritional cancer care slash treatment that we use in our clinic
that other people seek out. There's a Protocell 23 and a Protocell 50. They're available in
our store. There's often questions because some of the details that you may look at Protocell and
other sites talk about being careful with antioxidants, be careful with other things when you're
using Protocell. And the reason is is that Protocell is actually an oxidizing agent. So it's similar
to chemotherapy in the sense that you're using oxidation to treat the cancer.
Or chemotherapy as an oxidizing agent slash a poison. You don't want to use a lot of strong
antioxidants. At the time you're doing chemotherapy, it's similar with Protocell and we want to
kind of cover that. So when you're using Protocell, now if you're familiar with Protocell,
you'll understand there is a very exact time of day that you take the Protocell. You take it
depending on which you're taking either Protocell 23 or Protocell 50. You're taking it four-and-a-half
hour intervals or five-hour intervals. So every four-and-a-half or five hours, you're taking the product.
When you're taking that product, let's say you're taking it at eight o'clock in the morning,
you do not want to take anti-oxidant nutritional products at that same time. So it'd be best if you
stuck to solely the Protocell when you're taking the Protocell. Media at eight o'clock in the
morning, it's time to take your Protocell, you take your Protocell, any other nutritional products you
take midway between. If you're at a four-and-a-half-hour cycle, you take it at 10, 10, 15. That's what you'll
take your other supplements midway between. So no anti-oxidants take it at the same time that you would
take Protocell. No vitamin C, no alpha-low-pant, low-pork acid, no glutathione, and acetylcystine
curcumin, turmeric, vitamin E, coq10, quercetin. There's a few others. Anti-oxidants that are out there
don't take them at the same time that you would take the Protocell. You will kind of negate the power
of the Protocell because the Protocell works as an oxidizing agent and you're taking antioxidants,
you could negate the power of the Protocell. Just like if you're taking chemotherapy and you're
getting a chemotherapy IV, so you go in at night o'clock in the morning to get an IV of chemotherapy,
that's strong oxidizing agent. Your oncologist doesn't want you to take antioxidants. Well, we tell
people don't take antioxidants for 48 hours after you do an IV of your chemotherapy. That's what
it's really doing its job after that it's damaging healthy cells, then you get out of the antioxidants
and you help protect your healthy cells with the antioxidants. Same thing with the Protocell,
but you're taking that daily. Just keep it away midway between your doses. That's the secret with
taking oxidizing agents and using antioxidants to protect your healthy cells to help
deal with cancer in other ways other than what you're doing with Protocell. Another question we get
is with the RIFE machine. Some of the older Protocell posts out there will say don't use the RIFE
machine with Protocell. That's talking about the handheld grip electrical stimulation RIFE machines.
That's not talking about the light frequency RIFE machines, which in my book are really the only
type of RIFE machines using light frequency. So using a true RIFE or a GP4000 something like that
with the ball, you could use that right along with when you're taking the Protocell. So just understand
that. Another question we get is can you eat foods that have antioxidants? Should I stay away from
vegetables and oranges and good foods when I'm doing Protocell? The answer is no. So really what you
want to worry about is taking supplements with antioxidant. So if you're going to take Protocell
at 8 o'clock in the morning, can you eat breakfast that maybe you're going to eat at orange or maybe
you're going to eat some fruit that's that's high in antioxidants? I would not worry about that.
It can be good to wait a half hour after you take Protocell and keep Protocell away from food at
least a half hour. That might be a good practice, but don't worry about eating oranges or berries
throughout the day. Other foods that are high in antioxidants throughout the day. If you're going to
eat a lot of high quantities of that, again, choose to eat it between doses just like your supplements
and then you'll be fine. You want to protect your healthy cells. You want the Protocell to attack the
cancer. So with that in mind, keeps life simple when taking Protocell. You don't have to be crazy
about it. Just keep the things away from your doses. All right, thanks much.